the New England new head coach has just
come out and made clear the uh Dei
policies for the team I do see color
because I believe if you don't see color
you can't see racism and whatever
whatever happens black white disabled
person I've always even someone with
disabilities I always uh you know for
the most part people are like you know
don't you know when they're young they
they kind of make the spot hot younger
people know what that means but what I
would say is
like no I want you to be able to go up
to those people and really understand
those people so it goes back to whatever
it is black white yellow it really
doesn't matter but it does matter so we
can try to fix a problem that we all
know we have I see color because we got
to fix the racism the racism in football
yeah finally finally the black man is
going to have a fair Shake in the
National Football League you know it's
been a long time coming but I am so
relieved that finally we're going to see
a black guy playing football